voici la commune de sel dans l'hérault
en 1969 elle a pourtant bien failli
disparaître suite à la construction d'un
lac artificiel
les 77 habitants étaient alors
expropriés trois hameaux pradines c'est
l'ailé vaille et ne seront pas englouti
mais seront coupés du monde
hello viendra lécher les murs de leur
première maison celle devient alors une
véritable ville fantôme parmi les rues
désertes
un homme seulement joseph bienvenido
surnommé bichette et le gardien de la
commune qui était celle le village
depuis que les jeunes sommes partis des
gens sont venus piller
voilà il ne reste plus qu'aux
d'halloween des ruines des maisons vides
pourtant c'est la toujours son maire
henri goudal en 1982 il restait
profondément marqué par la situation
c'est toujours embêtant d'être chassé de
chez soi dans les années 80 grâce à
l'attachement de ses anciens habitants
celle reprend peu à peu des couleurs la
mairie les glissant réhabiliter
l'électricité le téléphone reviennent
mais les habitants sont toujours absents
pourtant 1990 même la nouvelle
génération n'avais qu'une seule envie
revenir habiter à celle vous vous êtes
jeune vous aimeriez revenir habiter cela
il ya tout à refaire on aime tout être
pas imméritée à celle tous les habitants
de la commune
les examens tard excusé moi veulent
demander ces lois des projets de
réhabilitation sont à l'étude
mais attention pour joseph bienvenido
l'âme du village hors de question de
changer quoi que ce soit je voudrais
qu'on leur tape mais alors dans les
pilotes auront pas de pad avait tort pas
de méthode en 2015
joëlle goudal alors maire du village et
fille de l'ancien maire henri goudal a
repris le flambeau de son père avec un
mot d'ordre est toujours la même envie
refaire de sel un vrai village faire que
son village avec une mixité sociale qui
y ait un développement économique et
pérenne cinquante ans après des
expropriations la vie s'apprête à
reprendre son cours à celle pour
l'actuel maire joëlle goudal 120
habitants devraient venir s'y installer
d'ici dix ans